des prisons
m
il a
il faut voir
emballé
ces fusions
là
et joli
charles
ses mains
la vie en
on a gagné on a perdu
maison
non
six mois un an avant
m
vim
il en livre
et
attention toujours là quand arrive
jamais
il en a le tocsin
ok
mais
il est en danger
paris
[Applaudissements]
paris total et
l'autre
à
là le roi
i
le
liberté liberté
macron ton face aux n'aurait pas
d'accroc dans passe au nord est
est ce que vous êtes change et puis
j'ai rien entendu est ce que vous étiez
est
ce que vous avez envie de claquer des
mains si peu pour vous échauffer
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux ta liberté et a compté mans
et tu veux ta liberté mans et tu veux ta
liberté si tu veux sa liberté si tu veux
ta liberté a tenté ma si tu veux pas
débat salutaire sa rentrée main
sais tu veux pas du pain sanitaire
tapantes et 20
si tu veux pas être salutaire si tu veux
paribas sanitaire si tu veux pas lui pas
sanitaire tape dans tes mains
si tu veux pas de macron tape dans tes
mains
s'il veut pas demain qu'on a dans ses
vins si tu veux pas de mâcon c'est sûr
je veux pas de mâcon si tu veux pas le
mac on tape dans tes mains
vous l'avez bien aimé césaire des noms
ne pas de macron tape dans ses mains
si tu veux pas de macron tape dans tes
mains
si tu veux pas de macron si tu veux pas
de mât feront si tu veux pas de mâcon
avant tes mains
si tu aimes la liberté à forte main
si tu aimes la liberté tendance et vince
situer sa liberté si tu aimes tu as
liberté si tu aimes sa liberté sa vente
et main
tout si tu veux qu'on ouvre tout tout de
suite pour tout le monde tape dans ses
mains
je veux tout pour tout le monde a dansé
ben
si tu vas t'on rien tout fait et tu veux
tout rires tout de suite
tu veux te liberté tape dans tes mains
les
libertés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour tous les réveillons
rebellin serré
[Musique]
exane ont en commun l'amour ok
tu réalises que la ville est pas là
le tabac
et si
[Applaudissements]
tous
elle
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'il ya
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends de l'italie
[Musique]
est ce que ça vaut le pen
à vos invités
c'est pas un inventaire
[Musique]
tu réalises
l'amour
[Applaudissements]
récit
que dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qui
[Applaudissements]
les i
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le jeu
tout se dire
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
il y a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque
gauche pleurent tout le temps que je
suis comme tout petit enfant comme tu
sais je sa fille sa maman ai dit que je
pleure tout le temps je suis carrément
méchant
non
en méchant jamais content
déjà mes parents dans le
l'éclat fr le challenge et les amis nos
grands pères des pharmaciens les
notaires qui trouvait carrément fugière
trésorerie
[Musique]
pierre
d'ordinaire puisant l'eau et d'office à
pau dans les parachutistes qui voulaient
que je tente des avions at rocher un
champignon je me régale
continueront
carrément tiendront
je suis sonné
angleterre chime super l'auberge des
cheveux et sourcils pour être plus grand
père dit
carrément tv
[Musique]
mais l'entente des chansons sur mon lit
une commande chanteur kabyle fallait que
je dise france à mes lignes un temps
agréable
dignité
[Musique]
avec un choix de ce tas de paille
il est tournée art on veut le bon les
petits garçons et of the gila
8e
mais pour eux car
bien fait pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle me dit que je pleure tout le temps
que je suis comme un tout petit enfant
qu un peu ces jeux sa fille sa maman on
dit que je peux tout le temps je suis
[Musique]
en échange jamais contents
et chante jamais content
on échange avec son temps
jamais
[Musique]
k
m
[Applaudissements]
egypte
il vient d'arriver et nous accueillons
fabrice ethève idiot
[Applaudissements]
alors
aujourd'hui il va falloir tendre
l'oreille parce que je suis à force de
crier dans les manifs j'ai pu voir
[Musique]
encore qu un peu quand même
manifestement
bien j'ai juste une chose à vous dire
est ce que vous vous êtes vu
tourner et vous tournez vous et regardez
vous
regardez vous
j'ai parlé qui est là tu apprends ce
qu'est la ga france qui prend le thé pop
indie nouvelle c'est la france qui prend
le départ de la résistance
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que ça lui va très bien sa
nouvelle voie
[Applaudissements]
vous aidera et nous sommes des millions
et dans le monde sont des milliards
et les lobbies mais l'espérance nous
allons nous battre
à tout à l'heure
on va gagner
[Applaudissements]
mais marron ton passe au non pas
aux normes
[Applaudissements]
on n'en veut pas maquereau thon passe
macro taux passe
est ce que j'aurai toujours
j'ai un petit service à vous demander ça
vous dit
on va faire une vidéo pour le sinistre
emmanuel macron on va lui dire ma
condition tous ensemble ça vous dit
mâcon
[Applaudissements]
m
oh
10 heures
vous n'êtes absolument fantastique vous
êtes des visages radieux vous avec la
france libre vous êtes des vivants vous
on va bientôt commencer mais gardons en
tête que nous sommes là cortège à paris
mais il y en a dans toute la france
bravo à tous les procès tous les process
qui se lève le nez
[Applaudissements]
et
gardez bien en tête que c'est dans
l'unité que nous gagnerons vacciner et
non vaccinés tous ensemble contre le
pain sanitaire de l'ocs
pis ensemble tous ensemble ouais
puissent ensemble tous ensemble
médicaux
[Musique]
jamais
m
jamais contents
[Musique]
janek
j'avais
jamais mi temps
[Musique]
m
on calme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dtp
j'ai pris 6
le virage est là
tél
on est
suite
[Musique]
et
c
g
[Musique]
le risque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
petit
j'ai pu lire
[Musique]
cela
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le ferai
comment
je retiens
[Musique]
beaucoup
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un sou
[Musique]
comme au match aller
super
un des palais du doigt
comme des taupes hollandais ce tracas
les nations
oh
ah ouais
là
hu
et
viens voir les comédiens
les
comédiens ont installé leurs très gros
ils ont dressé le risque sera défendue
pour les comédies à
la parade
devant l'église
avec les chaises
et derrière
viens voir les comédiens
qui arrive
voilà
qui arrive ces poulets
dans l'histoire
vié vous aimez bertrand rey où la mode
est surpris mais heureux
booth et l'emploi les entraînons vous
dans les gros coups autant dire
pour m
j'ai jamais
[Applaudissements]
bien
ce qui arrive aux lettres les dix ans
m
il laissera aux enfants des deux
espagnols
m
pouvoir aux abois
on a travaillé dans la nuit
mais quand même
bien
à l'école et bien les musiciens
c'est vrai
de là
je suis là
les musiciens les mafieux
non
est-ce que ça va toujours
est ce que vous êtes toujours déterminée
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont que j'ai
rencontrés qui ont fait beaucoup de
route pour venir je vois un drapeau
picard revoit tous les piqueurs
j'ai vu également des lieux des bravo à
tous les gens de rhône-alpes
ya des droïdes ans
bravo à toutes les france qui s'est
déplacé pour ce cortège national bravo
marrons aux pinces on n'en avait pas
on n'en veut pas
au nom de quoi
je vois que il ya aussi beaucoup de
personnes avec des pancartes en soutien
au professeur out
[Applaudissements]
touche pas à un
bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
alors autant de parisiens qui se
tiennent un marseillais c'est
suffisamment rare pour le souligner
bravo à tous et soutien après vente
vidic yoplait
tu es tout nus sont en cours via la rue
et ma boulangerie mot
taton caire at-on coup elle bonheur à
rots joli mot
talent rimmel quand c'est le dégel des
amants jolis mots
tu as très rhissa sampo présentons aux
admins joli bourg
tqui fleurs du printemps qui se couple
avec lui tant déplu une rose éclate et
que l'on pose à côté
ses coffres
[Musique]
ils pensent que l'école
baiser
[Musique]
mais
d
jours à la comté
à paris merci
tc
viollet
oh c'est bon
l'artiste
c'est une fleur
temple le résultat dès qu'une école
d'amour bokolo étoiles euros
aujourd hui morts et
c'est que fois est-ce que les y du
chagrin
dès qu'une chose d'harry connaît
compellent
est pour qui
julie maude
[Musique]
tac une rime au panel faut que ça rime
donc sa première démo
tap une source au milieu du club
chacune portant règlement
en chantant tous les maux
les qu'une petite fleur ou qui m'ont
avec humeur déculpe amma assis
cauchemarder france
les roms
dès qu'un joueur pas d'aller piocher
voilà
je l'aimé
tu es tout nu ce temps pour les salariés
tu m'as boucherie mort
[Musique]
je suis le poinçonneur des pleins
il vient qu'on croit c'est qu'on a des
visions france les miss lors de
l'émission un croc émission raconte
démission bako démission
mac os un come back
au
bac au
bacon
bacon temps passe on n'aurait pas trop
on n'en veut pas
on n'aimerait pas
un conte
est ce que vous voulez notre liberté
est ce que vous êtes et rino séance
liberté liberté
oui
m
[Applaudissements]
je suis poinçonnet de riz dans le khat
ont croisé contradictoires il ya trois
soleil sous la terre pour le troisième
pour tuer l'ennui j'ai dans ma veste les
extraits du reader digest et lens
boukari
légasse la coule douce à miami
pour l'instant que je préserve au fond
de la cave paris qu'il n'ya pas de sot
métier moi je fais les trous dans les
billets je fais des trous des p'tits
trous entre les petits trous des p'tits
trous des p'tits trous toujours les
petits trous des trous ce conclave
des troupes première classe un jeu fait
des trous des p'tits trous encore les
petits dons des petits trous des p'tits
trous toujours et qui quand les petits
trous des p'tits trous mais plutôt des
petits trous
je suis le poinçonneur des lilas
pour un rally de changer le terran
je vis au coeur la
gérante est un carnaval de conf les
isariennes jusque là en ligne et son
ciel de dubaï ans je ne vois rien que
les correspondants
moi j'aurais jeudi pendu je fais des
fringues pied par les ports et au bout
du quai je vois pas trop quelle chercher
une sortie de reuze tous fait des trous
des p'tits trous des p'tits trous
toujours est il fou mais le bateau
roussel taille
je vois que je ne dérape
ryan et je reste dans mon trou qu'avec
le coût est trop mou des tic où jal et
époux est plus petit monde est contrôlé
par des petites poubelles
[Musique]
pour un salaire des blancs
héritier direct par endroits
j'en ai marre j'en ai ma claque de ce
que je voudrais jouer la fille de l'air
ici ma casquette au vestiaire
[Musique]
si l'issue
touche pour aimer
jda retirer sur la croix rousse qui
coûte que coûte hauteur et si pour moi
il est plus temps je partirai
concurrents je fais des fous des petits
trous des p'tits trous des p'tits trous
des p'tits trous toujours les petites
roues hier le pavé
dingue de quattro
c'est un trou un petit trou il ya du
pitre où un titre ou un titre ou un
dernier coup très embêté raffarin aurait
dû parler tout chef d'état
j'aime au nouvel
os et
soyez prêts
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
liberté liberté
liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
alors on est prêt à partir pour se tenir
encore plus près on va s'échauffer une
dernière fois les mains tous ensemble
et que et c'est romain pour ce bien dans
sa vie est devenue un test
du de la liberté dans ses mains
[Musique]
un document
si tu veux ta liberté si tu de ta
liberté si tu ne te relis des fêtes a
tenté
si tu donnes le cortège partageant thé
la
sita henry commencé dans tes vingt cinq
ans et vingt ans ça tombe bien parce que
ses 20 ans on va partir et se faire
entendre tout paris
ouais je vois je suis en train de bouger
déjà pu se tenir avant tricolore vous
pourrez emmener
l'universel c'est leur terre
[Applaudissements]
là
je trouve
non
il est environ
pas le temps d'aller son pad en raison
des murs de masques et de crachats les
emmerdes à masquer les envers damas près
par le roi sont des taurillons macarena
georges ont sauté de passe
oui en chambre
[Applaudissements]
le progrès
thomas dans la mer on sera là
pas sûr que ce soit
parce que c'est un droit et
ils sont amis ils sont
bonjour
et
chaque besoin de la farcir arriver son
rôle de la france
espérons-le un expert ou l'autre élément
là
[Musique]
l'odeur de
riz en chantant
[Musique]
liberté
pour la mienne en soi
ce que le temps
m
les
la mort
l'état
soyez
nouvelle plaie ouverte et libertés du gp
liberté tirant des grandes ouvertes et
liberté liberté liberté
[Musique]
aux gens d'en face on ne rêve pas me
phung temps passe on en rêve pas un
conte ton pince on n'en veut pas
au comptage ordonné sa part trop tôt
parce qu'on aurait 20 barbour révision
[Applaudissements]
résistance résistance résistance
les experts
les
[Musique]
et à
oui
d
e
il y
ja
la vie
[Applaudissements]
avant
ok
il
m
et
arrivé
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
mais
et
[Musique]
là
je serai prêt
[Applaudissements]
et
sortie du jeu
[Musique]
et eux
le
m
[Musique]
oui
très ému
alors
le
[Musique]
u2
bon
emma
[Musique]
tu
veux
les
seniors
[Musique]
m
oui non
et
c'est que vigneault
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
et à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bâtiment
[Applaudissements]
magro magro
voilà
[Applaudissements]
à
bon d'accord on va
[Applaudissements]
non
à
[Applaudissements]
areva
l'ozone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
ouais
il est
m
[Applaudissements]
et
enfin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
il a
à
[Applaudissements]
jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
oh
r
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
obama
les jeux
et à
m
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
crois bien
[Applaudissements]
à
on va
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
m
il
à
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
déjà
je suis passé
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là on met
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ah ah
en bas
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
coppens
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
le dos
[Musique]
m
il
[Applaudissements]
selon l'aiea
hop
complices
pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
et
et vous
moi juge
on veut pas
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
je suis
sans voix
[Musique]
j
libérez
les
et on sait
oh
mais bon
voilà
on
va oh
à
le
ouah
et
vidéo
barco démission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
liberté m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
les
[Musique]
t
il n'en est rien
ce soir
là
et
[Musique]
m
je
le toit
ça
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
on
alors on va attendre que tout le monde
arrive quoi que je dois déjà plus loin
de la foule les gens sont en train
d'arriver bonjour à tous chevaux jours
vous avez l'air en forme
m
l'islam est midi et récupérez vos
libertés
et on dit pour macro qui va persévérer
pour des missions à compétition
jean
nous avons tous les romains cette forêt
de drapeaux français c'est absolument
magnifique bravo à vous vous êtes des
héros
[Applaudissements]
mapon télévision bas qu'on reddition aux
démissions un pôle télévision
ouais
est ce que vous avez toujours d'une
énergie
[Musique]
est ce que vous vouliez allumer le feu
e
mais ce
dîner liberté
[Applaudissements]
et
et des cris
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
le cas
qui se fait
à
ce sens
et en heure
vincennes
il dit
ok
et
non
bonsoir ou bonjour à tous bonjour la
france
bonjour la france libre
[Applaudissements]
revient alors il fera bon comme d'hab
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
alé lô
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais
non
à
[Applaudissements]
le rituel toujours d'en savoir dont nous
parlons trop gentil a pu nous y parle on
sait qu on n'a pas compris on pige pas
[Musique]
oui oui oui alors en temps j'ai vu une
affiche pour l'instant c'était l'été un
sans coeur
malgré qu elle rigole finiront par
tomber et je pense que nous pourrons
prendre sa part à bord aux communistes
les pierres sans coeur profit d'iss
malgré galles écosse 116 finiront un
jour par tomber c'est leur destin et
nous gagnerons
alors allons quand même par rapport à sa
parole par rapport aux journalistes de
plateau on parle beaucoup de médecins
plateau mais il faut dire que l'âme de
bon je crois des journalistes au plateau
mona qui sont à un quart d'heure d'ici
entre étudiants et
sur les plateaux et un comme si
nous étions sur une terra incognita
ils ne voient pas ils ne croient
délirant il le croit extrêmement sauvage
et nous croire deschamps
excusez moi ça un problème technique
donc pour un peu de progrès pendules à
l'heure quand même et dire à ces jours
là que bah non c'est les français et
françaises comme tout le monde et que
y'a pas de problème est que ici moi je
vois des français donc toute leur
diversité je vois la france il faudrait
qu'il le voit aussi avec l'arête
l'interview
en plus sur les plateaux il faut le
système est extrêmement chape fluide
pour bannir autre chose de bulles et
plaisant d'être bon il met d'un lit
donne par exemple du ve et florian
philippot interviewé et en invitant ils
font passer des images et base d'imagés
d'autres manifestations on vous avez les
gens qui sont totalement les crs les
encadrent complètement alors qu'ils ont
droit à manifester ces jours là bien
évidemment mais dit simplement c'est pas
nous c'est pas nous c'est pas possible
d'accord comme j'ai remarqué il n'y a
pas à nos gendarmes qui est la leur à un
crs qui est la vraie corps dont ils
manipulent sur une manipulation sans
[Applaudissements]
alors oui si on n'est pas en compétition
mais là pour rassembler rassembler par
rapport à une lutte qui est cette
liberté le monde nous regarde nous
sommes dans nos bottes et nous sommes
les français de france et de partout et
nous sommes
correctes police azer jamais vu même
après le passage rare dans les
manifestations qui nettoyaient la place
d'accord les bouts de papier qui
traînait jeu d'herbacées exemplaires
d'accord je vais écrire un un test je ne
recevons des lettres de deux jambes de
femmes et d'hommes qui qui ce qui fait
qu'ils aient envie de témoigner et il ya
des témoignages qui sont tout à fait
poignant tous les voleurs un témoignage
pour faire comprendre à ces gens là que
de quatre ans il s'agit des gens comme
ça voyez dynamique au gouvernement comme
celles que dont je vais vous lire la
lettre dit mme allier gouvernement il se
veut respectueuse il s'occuperait plus
du bien public pour les français il
serait plus correct dmp efficace que ce
qu'on a en ce moment gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jérôme daliot géorgie j'ai un ami je
suis très grande colère je ne vais plus
pouvoir aller à la bibliothèque de tours
ils ont mis plus de dix enfants puisque
je ne suis pas vacciné je refusais pour
voir lire et donner le goût de
donner le goût d'aller
très important puisque c'est la première
ouverture sur le monde et que je suis
une ancienne institutrice
tous ceux qui sont contre ce pays contre
ce pas ce pardon reste très unie malgré
vos différences de penser
quant à moi je suis disponible pour
distribuer des tracts amicalement une
grand mère qui veut la liberté pour ses
petits-enfants et
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
liberté liberté
liberté liberté liberté ninacs les
libertés liberté liberté
nous avons avec nous des procès qui sont
venus de tous les coins de l'hexagone
vingt
personnes qui sont venues de gros piège
depuis les frontières suisses de
bibelots
et nous avons la chance et l'honneur de
leur famille nous arrive à tous à tous
qui organisent des manifestations
précisément dans les vosges parce que
nos manifestations sont dans toute la
france et porte le message de la france
libre la france qui veut se libérer du
plus petit village de france jusqu'à
paris notre rassemblement grandiose fête
à tonnerre à bissau l'arrivée tous
autour
[Applaudissements]
il avait laissé ses bougies au havre où
quand même
heureuse d'être là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors chers compatriotes chers patriotes
sur un ami que je tiens à vous remercier
d'éclat aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir ça
fait chaud au coeur de voir tout ce
monde
[Musique]
et oui devoir obligations
mais khalid et là
je remercie tous mes collègues patriotes
de france parce qu'ils sont tous dans la
rue cet été moi j'ai commencé le 1er
route et on était trois cent cinquante
aujourd'hui on est 500 dans la rue
[Musique]
je profite de cette manifestation pour
remercier aussi toute mon équipe
vosgienne avec qui je travaille avait
coûté depuis début août et enfin fait un
travail formidable aujourd'hui ses
délégués la manifestation vosgienne
parce que il ya une très bonne
collaboration avec eux et je les
remercie de tout coeur bon florian un
grand bonjour des vosges même s'ils sont
pas là
et aussi je voulais dire que nous sommes
la seule force d'opposition dans la rue
pour défendre nos concitoyens merci
après un goûter offert ippon que ce
patch pour les citoyens depuis quarante
élire semaine
[Applaudissements]
j'apporte mon soutien on restera peur
qu'inspire
personnel soignant à toute le france
[Musique]
merci votre aisance sans vous on ne
ferait rien
je voulais aussi éclaircir un point qui
va un petit peu chiffonné à chaque fois
on nous traite d'anti vaccin on ne nous
sommes pas des anti vaccins qui sont des
anti passe et on est contre l'obligation
vaccinale
chacun a le droit de choisir de se faire
vacciner ou non
accéder au port nous donnons rester
unis
alors pas sa rentrée scolaire vous savez
très bien que nous allons vivre des
restrictions encore plus difficile à
battre on va encore nous faire des
siennes mais on va passer ses pairs des
amis on va résister
il faut résister pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants il faut leur donner les
semis retire de ce nom
et ce qui est terrible par cette crise
sanitaire c'est qu'on peut on a un peu
plus soigné correctement puisque c'est
le pass le peuvent de là
[Applaudissements]
le serment d'hippocrate et la
déontologie médicale n'ont plus aucun
sens puisque l'oligarchie à imposer une
dictature sanitaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ontario
il faut remettre de l'humanité au coeur
de notre société sans humanité nous ne
serons pas revivre normalement
soyons fiers femmes et la france soyons
bien d'autres combats
quoi qu'il arrive la flamme de la
résistance française ne doit pas
s'éteindre et ne s'éteindra jamais
il est fort
[Applaudissements]
liberté liberté
bon on passe au nord n'est pas très gros
combat au nom d'un cran comme un faux
nom ne pas trop ton pince
[Applaudissements]
je sais que je vous ai déjà dit par le
passé
d'enregistrer une vidéo mais là on va
faire la plus belle vidéo de la journée
pour quelqu'un je pense que vous aimez
pas pro mais qu'est ce que vous en
pensez d'emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
vous aimez bien les bagnoles accroc
alors
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
quitter qui démissionne
alors dit que tu ne sembles
tennis au
visage
oh
[Applaudissements]
il va regarder cette vidéo
tout fébrile tout ballon parce que la
france est dans la rue contre se passe
ailleurs
nous avons un nouveau combattant de la
liberté de la première heure il est
souverainiste il est économiste mais pas
l'économiste plateaux télé il travaille
sur le fond il travaille aussi sur
l'écologie il était là à 100 m place
bien laroque sous les fenêtres d'olivier
les rangs quand il y avait encore de la
pluie de la neige cet automne et cet
hiver il a depuis le début je vous prie
de faire un tonnerre d'applaudissements
infirmières
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous les résistants de nouvelles
prône la liberté
[Applaudissements]
je vous parlais de trois petites minutes
l'échec vaccinale de maquereau est
différent en décembre verrons nous a dit
vaccinez vous à tous les français et
vous allez retrouver votre liberté mais
quelle blague neuf mois plus tard il
utilise la vaccination pour nous piquer
nos libertés
sont absents c'est une technique
expérimentale mais n'a pas que la
technique c'est la fin de la pratique de
vers en oc et expérimental au départ
c'était prenez de deux heures vous serez
tranquille maintenant c'est on va
rajouter dans une petite troisième ou
une quatrième et puis finalement une
tous les six mois
bonjour petite hausse de djendjen on
pensait alors ajouter une dose de
freezer
des ressemble à un apprenti sorcier qui
touille sa potion et la teste sur des
cobayes
et pourtant il y tenait d'israël sont
formels
en fait ce vaccin n'empêche pas
d'attraper la maladie son efficacité
baisse et est divisé par deux tous les
six mois son efficacité contre les cas
graves qui un terrain à tous baisse
aussi donc quel est l'intérêt de tout
cela la logique tordue c'est de dire
puisque ça marche pas va représenter
représenter une dose au
les données islandaise anglaise israël
maltaise dit tout la même chose ça
n'empêche pas d'attraper la maladie et
de contaminer les autres c'est clair
donc il n'ya rien d'égoïste a refusé de
se faire vacciner
[Applaudissements]
des égoïstes ce n'est pas vous je ne
font pas d'écran très active et on
balaie les héroïnes sont vaincrons et
verront qu'ils sont incapables d'assumer
leurs échecs de leurs stratégies
vaccinales
ils sont incapables peut faire de la
prévention depuis 18 mois alors que la
vitamine d et le zinc sans vie ils sont
incapables de soutenir le protocole de
raho et des autres qui sauvent des vies
alors égoïste le dernier buzz est trop
faible parce qu'ils ont du sang sur les
mains à ne pas vouloir sauver des vies
c'est criminel le bon pour moi
[Applaudissements]
alors tous les produits pharmaceutiques
surtout les techniques et mentales jour
recèlent toujours des risques
mais là effectivement il ya des données
thomas coville ans nous disent même si
tout est pas répertorié même s'il faut
normalement d'après la littérature
multiplié par 10 ou sans les effets
secondaires il y aurait mille morts et
quinze villes effet un dixième de gramme
post vaccination
donc c'est une mise en danger pour moi
d'autrui des personnes en bonne santé et
qu'ils n'ont aucun risque et qui ont
moins de 60 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi tout ça
parce que ce pouvoir aux abois enfin
après totalement d'autre choix que de
vous piquer vos libertés pour vous
contrôler parce qu'il ya aussi quelque
chose de pire c'est en fait une
stratégie électorale de macron il
raconte une propagande qui et n'importe
quoi sur la vaccination qui va tous
sauvés et en même temps il fait peur aux
personnes âgées et ils disent à regarder
ces gens dangereux dit que ne veulent
pas le pas de sanitaires voter pour moi
aux présidentielles parce que moi je
vous défends c'est du chantage c'est une
instrumentalisation
abjecte sur nouri sur nos libertés
ce vaccin de grippe manière ne résout
pas la crise on le sait et il met même
en risque notre santé mais il met
surtout en risque nos libertés et le
premier mot de la devise de la france
ces libertés liberté égalité fraternité
et de nous ne céderons jamais
c'est son choix que vous êtes des
fidèles depuis six ans et un mois d'août
et que vous avez faite aux constructeurs
de manifestation et c'est pour cela
qu'ils font est habillé la semaine
prochaine des critiques le 4 septembre
pour faire céder macron pour les obliger
à retirer le pinceau la honte
[Musique]
il résiste vive la france et vive la
liberté
[Applaudissements]
liberté liberté
il est inerte et libertés y verrait
liberté
alors est ce que vous aimez surprise
ça tombe bien on allait une fois de plus
nous sommes fidèles à leur engagement et
on est là notamment en soutien un homme
de courage qui est persécutée en ce
moment en compte dans cette élite dans
cette dérive tyrannique de vue la france
en ce moment je ne sais pas si vous
voyez bien le message
vous voyez probablement ce qu'il a écrit
là bien écrit sur cette balle une fois
de plus touche pas à la route puisque
nous allons le réaffirmer notre soutien
au professeur out
soutien à un
soutien
tous bien
racine et non vaccinés nous sommes tous
unis contre le pas solitaire et ou sans
soutien au professeur route
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes là pour la liberté et nous
sommes là notamment pour la liberté de
nos grands chercheurs et de nos grands
médecins ceux qui depuis le début très
très malade peut continuer à exercer
vive le professeur raout
[Applaudissements]
on vous dit
les scores pas vous êtes tellement vieux
et en même temps j'apprends de cette
semaine que jean pierre elkabbach
84 ans
reprend du service
il faut laisser la place aux jeunes bien
sûr
voilà où aller on a mérité pour
professeur raout on la connaît tous
c'est qu'il faut surtout on perd occuper
la place par les médiocres
beaucoup de place pour l'excellence en
france
l'opic place pour la vérité en france
est le premier qui dit la vérité devrait
être exécuté et c'est pour ça que
ensemble nous pouvons dire tous pareils
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez entendu vous avez entendu
sur ces news vous dire combien il était
touché par soutien vous l'avez entendu
dire la reconnaissance de cet homme qui
n'est pas dans la différence quant à lui
mais qui est touché par ce soutien qui
est le vôtre alors vraiment nous faisons
lui cette ovation majeur
[Applaudissements]
à
j'aimerais en tête et berkeley iversen
liberté
[Applaudissements]
m
nous avons
dans notre combat
à coeur le fait de défendre
toute la nation et en particulier les
plus jeunes d'entre nous et les autres
corps en particulier
[Applaudissements]
la jeunesse qu'il s'agisse des enfants
des jeunes sont parmi les plus touchés
par ces mesures sanitaires idiote
liberticide est tout simplement honteux
ce qu'on peut d'ailleurs hué
[Musique]
nous avons avec nous un enfant de la
france qui organise avec son collectif
des rassemblements dans toute la france
c'est un ami un ami à moi et c'est votre
ami à vous tous vous le connaissez vous
l'avez déjà écouté il s'agit des
fondateurs du collectif peuple libre
rémi tales
et riches à l'ouest mais le jeu
quelques montres et rapidshare premiers
résistants
à la fin d'un été durant lequel vous
avez consacré bien dès samedi à une vie
digne de votre en position passe de la
honte dire notre opposition à la
vaccination obligatoire oui ce combat
est long et ce combat est difficile
comme toutes les batailles qui mérite
d'être véritablement mené on n'a pas
combattu l'apartheid l'apartheid secours
en afrique du sud en quelques semaines
on n'a pas comparu les dictatures
d'amérique du sud en quelques semaines
alors il va falloir tenir bon et nous
tiendrons bon ensemble
jeunes allaient terminer par cette
phrase du général de gaulle qui nous
rappelle la chose suivante
et qui nous y invite soyez ferme pure et
fidèle au bout de nos peines
nous connaîtrons la plus grande gloire
du monde celle des hommes qui n'ont
jamais cédé nous n'aurons rien céder et
nous ne savons rien
m
et après liberté liberté
liberté
[Applaudissements]
de ton pince pour ne pas
tomber on ne veut pas
toucher aux impôts
pas touche à mon pot
dans cette crise crise démocratique
les médecins que ce soit hospitalier où
les médecins du quotidien les
généralistes et les soignants en général
sont parmi les plus touchés sont parmi
les plus contraints par les choix
d'olivier ferrand et d' emmanuel macron
mais beaucoup d'entre eux ont décidé
d'entrer en résistance blois tous les
soignants qui sont rentrés en les
boutons
[Applaudissements]
la semaine dernière deux années avec
tout le collectif des soignants d'île de
france opposé justement à cette
obligation vaccinale est opposé à ce pas
sanitaires nous avons aujourd'hui un
autre soignants entrer en résistance qui
est du bon côté il est médecin il
s'appelle gauthier écoutons ce message
mais avant tout applaudissons son
courage
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
je suis un vieux médecin généraliste un
médecin de campagne à la françois cluzet
ou plutôt un médecin de famille
[Applaudissements]
il ya 48 heures je prêter un serment que
j'ai tout mon exercice professionnel
je me suis installé un petit village
gaulois avec comme assistant l'astérix
des bagarres on est aussi une solidarité
incroyable des gens avec un coeur gros
comme ça et un bon sens que je nommerais
paysans avec une connotation admirative
aux nuages qui m'ont accueilli à bras
ouverts j'ai vu naître et grandir leurs
enfants incitent les enfants de leurs
enfants j'ai vu aidé à mourir dans la
dignité dix anciens mais aussi à mon
grand désarroi est beaucoup plus jeune
personne n'a jamais empêché aucun être
vivant nourrir je peux dire que la
proximité de ces gens on m'a fait penser
que je faisais un peu partie de leur
famille leur donne pour exemple mon
invitation aux banquettes betten au
mariage également aux légumes et aux
douzaines de poser devant la porte de
façon anonyme
pour eux
j'ai suivi ce que l'on m'avait enseigné
d'abord ne pas nuire en utilisant toutes
les ressources de la thérapeutique
quelle qu'elle soit mais aussi surtout
en les écoutant
[Applaudissements]
l'explosion a investi en tant que je
préside l'association des médecins
régulateurs libéraux en participant aux
régulations j'ai été maître de stage
pour transmettre l'expérience du terrain
aux étudiants
les voilà qui a émis un livre devenu
ching bouleverseront l'eau pas toujours
tranquille certes mais dans l'ensemble
peu tumultueuse toulon les cloches du
mal à retrouver les valeurs que le vent
inculqué j'essaye toujours de soigner en
m'aidant de ce bon sens que vit pas sur
mon transmis j'y arrive tant bien que
mal je conseillais trait sur lens qu'il
me semble juste
17 août c'est l'apocalypse
depuis il ne fout je suis en dehors des
clous n'ayant pas reçu une injection
antico mid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et à partir du 15 septembre sur ma
position je serai interdit d'exercer
[Applaudissements]
et mme expose à des sanctions pénales
s'ils n'obtempèrent pas
interdit d'exercer telle qu'elle est
jolie
qu'elle changeait dans la pratique de
plano et demi pour me gect le créneau et
demi j'ai travaillé en respectant tous
les moyens qu'ils éviteraient
propagation virale au début grâce à des
patients qui m'ont donné des masses je
peux même n'en avions pas des blues des
combinaisons on désinfecte en ligne
beaucoup et je le fais bien sûr toujours
je suis en retraite dite active depuis
le début de l'année afin d'organiser
tout selon mon départ pour mes patients
qui auront du mal à trouver un médecin
pour les accueillir dans une région déjà
sinistrée par les départs en retraite lé
17 confrères alentours et la bruche
collines l'arrêt d'activité il va poser
bien des problèmes aux cas les plus
graves et aux personnes âgées à domicile
le 14 juillet 2001 j'étais invitée aux
célébrations comme représentant des
médecins du département et madame jet
laissez-nous il passera une fois
organisé en douceur mon départ en fret
comme nous nous organisions ensemble
quand ils achètent du lot quand il
s'agissait du grand départ de certains
deux ans toute humanité
merci à vous tous on est loin de vous
[Applaudissements]
merci didier est l'homme des libertés
simplement nous permettent de partager
et non seulement de l'énergie de la
foule mais aussi des témoignages et des
témoignages parfois vibrant bravo à
wauthier pour son courage
[Applaudissements]
ils feront tout pour nous diviser ils
feront tout pour essayer de séparer d'un
côté les vaccinés de l'autre côté et non
vaccinés d'un côté les médecins d'un
autre côté les patients mais nous sommes
tous unis et
macro véran castex le savent ce n'est
que l'on essayant de semer la division
qu'ils résident qui resteront à la tête
et aux commandes de tout ça puisque en
france le souverain ce n'est pas ma
crise n'est pas emmanuel premier
ou rose
le soir c'est au peuple le souverain
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
quand seul dans ce combat
dans cette lutte acharnée entre la
liberté et la tyrannie le pass et la
liberté il y à un combattant que vous
connaissez bien
il
[Musique]
il est très humble ils n'aiment pas trop
qu'on l'a clamé je ne pourrais pas vous
empêcher de la kb
il est avocat
il défend tous ceux dans le monde de la
santé où dans le monde professionnel qui
veulent simplement exercer leur métier
il s'agit de fabrice di vizio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que vous êtes complètement
indisciplinés la raison d'être
ça fait des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines que je vous dit pas
d'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
et alors
je vais vous dire pourquoi quand mais je
vais quand même vous dire pourquoi
c'est pas de la fausse humilité
c'est sympa de se faire applaudir le dos
rêvez pas
mais c'est pas ça tout à l'heure
quelqu'un m'a dit dans la foule habibou
mais dit quelque chose au début de la
vanille je ne suis qu'un agent et je les
reconnais
en dix ans mais ça n'a pas de dire ça je
ne suis qu'un anonyme ça veut dire quoi
je ne suis qu'un anonyme vous êtes vous
quoi vous n'êtes pas déjà de nîmes vous
n'êtes pas des numéros
absolument pas y a pas d'un côté ceux
qui sont sur le podium et de l'autre qui
sont très écoutés les vrais résistants
et les histoires du quotidien ses goûts
jean pas lesquels sonorités
et c'est pour ça que voltaire je vais
effectivement vous qualifié d'ami vous
êtes des amis vous êtes nos amis car ici
car ici en ces lieux de sa vie en
famille nous allons april est ici rien
na li té le lien indéfectible amitié le
lien indéfectible d'hommes et de femmes
il dit par un bien commun unis par le
seul désir de vérité par le seul désir
de la liberté par les choses désir qu'on
leur foute la paix
et on est ici
alors concrètement très nettement
je voudrais vous dire deux choses deux
choses importantes d'or c'est combien
est effectivement je suis admiratif de
semaine en semaine de votre courage ici
il y as je voulais dit les vieux amis
ceux de la première heure et il ya ceux
qui peut être nous rejoignent
aujourd'hui par hasard ou par conviction
sachez que vous êtes les bienvenus que
vous êtes les amis qui s'il n'y a pas de
vacciner deux nous vacciner de blanc de
noir de grand
dans cette cité
dynamique sonore s'être qu'on est un peu
de
[Applaudissements]
tout ça nous sommes pas battus dans
l'histoire contre les petits bancs pour
venir il est évidement vous laisser
emmerder par atik et légumes en sortent
du barça fort et et alizé cornet
alors alors viens vous j'ai deux mondes
c'est le bon courage du courage vous
allez en avoir besoin et vous le savez
la pression monte vous êtes avant ce qui
était prudent on les appelait des
prudents s'inquiéter pour la liberté on
les appelait des résistants aujourd'hui
voici qu'on les appelle des connards
mais la vérité c'est qu'il n'en demeure
pas mois que vous êtes les histoires
vous êtes des combattants de la liberté
d'une part et donc des ordres le courage
d'avouer falloir parce que vous allez
continuer de subir la pression et la
moquerie mais nous sommes là nous sommes
je voulais 10 des habits et les indices
à centraide ça ce soutien les aliments
ça ne laisse pas tomber les uns et les
autres nous sommes ensemble vous n'êtes
pas seul sait comment situez saga si la
mort avec vous pour vous aider
samedi
deux manches au
2e d'un crash ans que je sais maintenant
à propos des enfants ne cédez pas ne
sais pas où ça va être difficile bien
suivre la pression va être dur la
pression va être terrible on va vous
culpabiliser on va vous faire peur on va
effectivement vous me cassez mais de
grâce ne s'était pas
les seuls à nous ça nous a tous chanson
tout à l'heure je serai là dans
l'attenté des rencontres comme chaque
semaine cette semaine nous organisons
des conférences pour les libéraux pour
les salariés nous tenons ce que nous
avons du temps nous offrons notre temps
et vous nous offrez votre générosité en
retour vous ne vous ferez votre
abnégation retourner votre courage nous
tenons grâce à vous dans nos vies chacun
ici nous tenons grâce à vous c'est par
vous que nous tenons vous pensiez te
dire pardoux alors que celle inverse
c'est par vous que nous tenons c'est à
vous que nous devons reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]
je suis tous là tous moi je serai là
tout à l'heure vraiment protégeons nos
enfants
[Applaudissements]
on se pose encore touche pas aux enfants
ou qui donnent encore
son chantage sur les enfants est
particulièrement honteux
j'essaie de faire pression pression
scolaire pression sociale pression sur
les chances de réussir avoir une
éducation et une belle vie pour nos
enfants et mettre tout ça au bout une
vaccination obligatoire
face à cela il faut être déterminé et
rester sur notre ligne de conduite c'est
à dire laisser les personnes qui veut
être vaccinés se fera signer mais
surtout obliger personnes et laissé la
liberté vaccinale de 0 à 100 ans
[Applaudissements]
touche pas à mon enfant
je dis que je croise entendu tous les
aînés dans les ehpad ceux qui sont chez
eux doivent pas non plus être
victimes que cet apartheid sanitaire qui
est en train d'être mis en place on
refuse à des enfants à des petits
enfants le droit d'aller voir leurs
aînés quelle société victime
nous voulons une société ni une société
fraternelle entre toutes les générations
c'est pas les jeunes contre les vieux
haute c'est tous ensemble et on peut le
dire une fois encore tous ensemble tous
ensemble
tous ensemble tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
pour la
41e semaine
quarante et une semaine de lutte dans la
rue prévost pour votre implication
[Applaudissements]
alors pour votre constance
pour son courage
et bravo à tous les nouveaux venus nous
n'avons jamais été aussi nombreux
pravind vous
c'est tous unis à paris comme dans toute
la france est perdu et que nous
reprendrons toutes nos libertés dans ces
rassemblements je suis très content
d'être à ce 41e rassemblement
assemblement qui ont été initiés
ya plus de 40 ans vous l'avez entendu
pas un homme qui au départ est descendu
dans la rue avec une poignée de
combattants déterminer
sous la pluie
sous la neige
sous les
sous les moqueries dans la différence
des adversaires et gars tic et politique
que tout le monde était chez lui lui est
sorti dehors pour dire aux gens de se
lever il s'agit de florian
niveau
[Applaudissements]
re bonjour à tous
je vous donnais en début de
manifestation si vous étiez en forme
j'ai ma réponse vous péter le feu bravo
pour cette
41e semaine d'affilée
effectivement dans déplaise au préfet
dalmore et à monsieur dharmanand nous
sommes des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers
alors parfois
parfois on peut demander aux demandes
mais pourquoi vous faites tout ça
pourquoi vous manifester chaque week-end
depuis quarante et une semaine n'avait
rien d'autre à faire
celui-ci s'il faut confier on a plein de
choses à faire on a aussi une vie et
pour deux raisons d'abord un on n'a rien
à gagner mais on a des valeurs à
défendre
on a une conception de l'homme
du monde et de la france à défendre
alors l'homme intéressés ne pourra pas
comprendre ce que je viens de dire le
cynique rires ah
mais l'homme de bien nous écoutera et
viendra avec nous
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes
toutes et tous ici des femmes et des
hommes de bien vous incarnez cette
flamme de la résistance qui ne veut pas
s'éteindre qui ne s'éteindra pas
maquereau au rap aux souffles et de
toutes ses forces plus il soufflera plus
qu'il ravivera notre flamme
[Applaudissements]
teheran
la coupe a dit cette semaine
que le pas salutaire pourrait être
prolongée même après le 15 novembre
et doudi le critère je le cite c'est
jusqu'à ce que le virus disparaisse de
nos villes
eh bien là quand on entend ça on se dit
qu il y a le feu au lac et qu'on risque
d'en prendre pour perpétuité car qui
décidera que le virus aura décidé aura
disparu nous ne pouvons pas accepter
qu'ils décident à notre place notre
liberté ne se découpe pas en doses de
produits fire ou moderna elle est totale
et aller intégral
[Applaudissements]
d'autres jeux rouge de doses feu manche
trois doses chever mais non nous quand
on entend ça on se dit on grille le feu
[Applaudissements]
oui nous n'avons rien à gagner mais nous
avons l'avenir à défendre pour éviter
que le monde de demain soit celui de
l'apartheid médical délit légaliser
celui de la surveillance numérique
généralisée dans lequel les mots liberté
égalité
des noix dignité humanité se
retrouverait au grenier parmi les
vieilleries de l'histoire non nous ne
l'acceptons pas pour nous ces mots sont
d'une brûlante actualité
[Applaudissements]
nous ne testons
l'apartheid sous toutes ses formes alors
on se bat
nous chérissons la liberté alors on se
bat
nous voulons protéger les enfants de
l'appétit vorace des industries
pharmaceutiques et de leurs obligés
politique et médiatique alors on se bat
nous voulons l'accès aux soins pour tous
alors on se bat
nous voulons qu'ils rouvrent des lits à
l'hôpital et qu'ils embauchent des
infirmières plutôt que des vigiles pour
contrôler les qr codes alors on se bat
nous respectons nous aimons nos
soignants nous respectons nous admirons
nos pompiers alors on se bat
tous à attacher au combat social au
progrès social alors nous n'acceptons
pas que dès lundi les salariés puissent
être viré jetés comme des kleenex parce
qu'ils n'auraient pas leur place a dit m
plus que nous portons ce combat social
que les grandes organisations syndicales
ont honteusement déserté à ça
nous aimons la france libre et ce
qu'elle incarne dans le monde de justice
de liberté de beauté et de grandeur
alors mes chers amis résistants aux
saupin
[Applaudissements]
et la question est pourquoi vous compact
et pourquoi vous êtes la
deuxième réponse
pour donner les nécessaires coups de
boutoir afin de faire tomber
définitivement leurs murailles de
mensonges
[Applaudissements]
et coup de boutoir ont déjà été données
ce sont ces terrasses de la liberté qui
commence à naître partout en france et
je salue reims cette semaine
et nous allons dès lundi
multiplié dans toutes les villes de
france ces terrasses de la liberté il y
aura les terrasses de l'apartheid yd il
y aura les terrasses du peuple et la
liberté plein fouet
[Applaudissements]
des collants noirs sont donnés ce saut a
de plus en plus nombreux à cheveux vous
le certifier ses bistrots ses cafés et
restaurants qui le contrôlent déjà plus
le pass brown
[Applaudissements]
on les autres cocottes
chaque classe
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce boycott qui commencent à être
entendus et nous voyons des professions
et des représentants qui commence à
aller à la télévision pleurnicher pour
le retrait du passani terre alors il
faut amplifier
puis coup de boutoir sont donnés celli a
su de marseille qui ne contrôle pas le
pass pour soigner les gens bravo
et nous rappelons ici comme nous l'avons
fait tout à l'heure d'autres
indéfectible soutien au professeur raout
mais aussi un loup il push et aux
professeurs peron et à tous les médecins
qui soignent les malades
[Applaudissements]
à
écoute route voire sont donnés ce sont
ces préfets contraint par la justice de
retirer leurs arrêtés de la honte
instaurant le pas salutaire dans des
centres commerciaux le préfet des
yvelines s'est fait avoir à les observer
gages
et bientôt se dégagera partout en france
quant au préfet du nord il a préféré
prudemment reculer et ne pas apposer
pour le moment de passani terre dans les
19 centres commerciaux ils devaient être
mises en place là vous voyez quand on
est là il recule ces gens là il suffit
de se montrer et de crier plus fort
[Applaudissements]
un énorme bravo par ailleurs ou
soignants des antilles qui ont fait
reculer vers ans aux antilles pas
d'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants
[Applaudissements]
de métropole est d'ailleurs en outre mer
vous avez là un motif d'espoir quand on
se lève suffisamment nombreux et qu'on
crie suffisamment fort dans la paix
comme vous le faites ici alors les vers
en est toute cette clique sont obligés
de chaque cacher
[Applaudissements]
coups de boutoir sont koné ce sont ces
grèves illimitées qui commence t'elle a
redit aux galeries lafayette à paris
bravo
soutient
60 ces craintes du bibliothécaire à
grenoble allons à toulouse i partout ce
n'est contre la passe de la honte qui va
également contre la culture et l'accès
aux livres et non décidément honte de
rien mais ça nous le savons nous n'avons
qu'une chose à leur dire il est temps de
partir
[Applaudissements]
alors ils sont nerveux
on la sent cette nervosité chez monsieur
les rangs on le sent nerveux et
tellement nerveux qu'il en est contraint
de mentir ainsi
olivier ferrand d'éclat que le
professeur out est touché par la limite
d'âge à la tête d'heuliez h et marseille
il ment et il le sait c'est un menteur
[Applaudissements]
ep fiez vous mesdames et messieurs les
et 20 heures car à la fin des vins soeur
finissent évincé
[Applaudissements]
et coup de boutoir sans koné et ce sont
ces pays qui met à la poubelle le pass
annie terre ce sera le cas le 1er
septembre prochain du danemark qui par
ailleurs danemark rouvrir à tous et
récupère à toutes ces libertés sans
exception le 10 septembre prochain bravo
[Applaudissements]
bravo aux figures détracteurs qui
inspire et si les gaulois réfractaires
hazeaux
parions que le danemark suivra dans le
sens inverse le même chemin que le
royaume uni qui a récupéré ses libertés
le 19 juillet prochain d'abord il
récupère ses libertés ensuite il
récupère sa souveraineté en quittant
l'union européenne et nous ferons le
ferait si fier
m
[Applaudissements]
oui si chaque semaine depuis quarante et
une semaine nos poitrines se gonfle
d'air pour créer liberté c'est parce que
nos coeurs sont confl et d'espérance et
que nos âmes sont gonflés à bloc pour le
combat et pour la victoire
pour sal et
on va gagner
[Applaudissements]
à
voilà
[Applaudissements]
oui on va gagner oui on ne peut que
gagner vous savez qu'elle a faim la vie
et la france gagne toujours
[Applaudissements]
legrand cicéron 10 et plus
l'effondrement d'un empire est proche
plus ces lois sont fun alors pour le lis
que nos lois sont de plus en plus folle
on peut être certain que l'on pire du
mensonge et bientôt au point de
disparaître hello bord de son
effondrement
[Applaudissements]
vous ne l'achetez pas
les deux nous l'annoncent nous irons et
le 4 septembre en donnera un avant goût
particulièrement succulent vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir nous irons
pour gagner jusqu'au blocage général et
jusqu'à la grève générale
[Applaudissements]
nous ne lâcherons rien
rien tant que macro castex véran et
leurs maîtres
ne laisserons pas la place aux seuls
souverains de france c'est à dire vous
et moi c'est à dire le peuple de france
ouais
ue ne lâcheront rien tant que notre
france éternelle celle qui est tombée
sans foi et c'est 100 fois relevés plus
au
n'aura pas repris le cours glorieux de
son histoire non pas une histoire le qr
code de masques de plexiglas et deux
passes annie terre mais une histoire
faite d'hommes et de femmes a franchi
libres responsables se battant en
permanence pour leurs unités y compris
contre leurs dirigeants qui veut les
diviser carc unis des français saute
relative
[Applaudissements]
c'est cette france là
multimillénaire cette france de la
gloire des victoires de la liberté et de
la grandeur qui nous inspire tous en
sommes les héritiers et nous avons le
devoir de la transmettre aux générations
qui viennent alors on se pince et nous
répondons à ceux qui on demande pourquoi
vous vous battez eh ben on se bat pour
ça précisément parce que nous nous avons
fois encore en quelque chose en
l'occurrence nous avons foi en l'homme
en ses valeurs et à notre chère patrie
et on la laissera pas tomber
[Applaudissements]
rita libertaire il la résistance et pis
la canche
ces journées liberté
m
[Applaudissements]
allons enfants
louvroil
[Musique]
et
non
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste pour vous dire que je suis là
enfin je crois la fin par là bas je suis
par la suite n'ont pas là la détente
des tanks là bas je serai dedans je
pourrais pas répondre à tout le monde
mais on s'y attache on a des permanences
mais ça en place mais déjà je suis là
[Applaudissements]
alors il faut absolument effectivement
en permanence bénévoles de fabrice di
vizio l'attend là bas comme il le fait
depuis plusieurs manifestations et
franchement aux soins qu'on peut
l'applaudir c'est incroyable
c'est magnifique ce qui fait
pour vous pour nous tous
on en reparlera d'ici là mais vous avez
noté le samedi 4 septembre toute la
france monte à paris le 4 septembre je
peux vous dire que j'ai des informations
ça va être extraordinaire
sans ordinaire
numéro pas en faire des cauchemars
voilà donc rendez vous le 4 septembre
prévient tout le monde on va en parler
des six la halle et amusez-vous passer
du bon temps il fait beau détendez vous
prenez ce temps pour vous il faut être
joyeux aussi vive la liberté vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
leeds bon encore merci à vous vous avez
des stands a des yeux long des stands de
bages descente pour les livres etc et
puis on va vous savez que ça coûte très
cher je vais passer parmi vous et des
militants à nouveau passer parmi vous
pour faire une petite pièce avec eux la
crise et vous la connaissez la colère
c'est terrible on est côté trop vous
savez quand on a un problème de passes
sanitaires c'est la même chose alors on
va passer par niveau avec le sac liberté
c'est vrai que ça coûte très cher vous
avez vu qu'ils aient pas de crs on a sur
nous mêmes les services dans sa fuite
chasse aux prochaines cinq autres encore
plus cher au centre encore plus nombreux
merci à vous pour ce que vous pourrez
faire le geste qui pourrait faire
merci à vous et bravo
liberté d'hiver près des libertaires
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez compris il y à
l'installation de dos est libre la
boutique de loin parlant de
relater les faits une dernière qui se
pose
est ce que vous auriez
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
alors oui
cet ordre
unique
[Musique]
à
m
et son début
comment
[Musique]
allez
puis le prendre
parce que non
je suis
toujours
[Musique]
la course qui ravit
en
chantant
non
[Musique]
et
comme moi
g
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
le monde
oh
oui
m
non
je t'aime
ouais
les biens et célia sont attendus devant
la scène pour rejoindre leur maman ne
dit rien laissé bien merci beaucoup
devant la scène tout devant la scène
devant la tribune lydia et ses liens
[Musique]
à
m
aulas
ah ah
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
mais
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le temps
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
hahaha
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
g
auparavant
[Musique]
à
tiens
[Musique]
oh
oh non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]